et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
marine turchi bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes journaliste au
pôle enquêtes de mediapart et vous êtes
à l'origine des révélations de votre
journal sur les accusations de viol et
de tentative de viol dont l'actuel
ministre des solidarités damien abad
fait l'objet accusations qui ont secoué
les premières semaines du second mandat
d' emmanuel macron et qui continueront
peut-être de le faire on va y revenir
d'abord quelques précisions sur les
faits pour ceux qui nous regardent et
qui ne les connaissent pas forcément
vous avez en deux fois et à peu près à
un mois d'intervalle sorti deux enquêtes
dans médiapart dans lesquelles vous
faites par donc des accusations de viol
ou de tentative de viol de trois femmes
qui ne se connaissent pas à l'encontre
de damien abad aujourd'hui donc ministre
des solidarités mais qui avant cela a
été entre autres choses député patron
groupe eurodéputés on parle d'une
enquête que vous avez commencé à la fin
de l'année 2020 oui absolument ça a été
une enquête très longue très difficile à
la base j'ai reçu un mail une alerte
d'une des trois femmes que vous évoquez
qui me dit je ne sais pas si vous avez
connaissance d'autres fait d'autres
victimes potentielles mais voilà mon
récit effectivement là on est aux
vacances de noël 2020 donc à la rentrée
2000 21 janvier 2021 je vais commencer
cette enquête qui va durer un an et demi
ça veut pas dire que tous les jours je
travaille sur cette enquête mais ça veut
dire que c'est le temps qu'il faut aussi
pour pouvoir convaincre les gens de
parler quand je dis les gens c'est pas
forcément que les victimes présumées
c'est aussi les témoins étaient moins
les confidents et je crois que c'est la
force de ces deux volets d' enquête
qu'on a publié sur médiapart c'est que
au delà de ces trois familles à toute
une série de témoins et puis aussi
d'autres femmes d'ailleurs qui dénonce
d'autres agissements qui décrivent un
député qui serait ainsi ce temps lourd
par message il ya beaucoup de sms dans
cette enquête de messages écrits et puis
ces trois femmes elles se sont confiés
au fur et à mesure des années chacune à
peu près une dizaine de personnes et ces
personnes je les ai interviewé justement
pour pouvoir reconstituer tout sert ici
ce qui me frappe c'est que j'entends
beaucoup que ces témoignages sont
anonymes pour moi ces femmes ne sont pas
anonymes moi je les ai rencontrés il ya
des noms derrière que j'ai pu vérifier
il ya des histoires où il ya les
trajectoires qu'elles disent reese et
pour certaines face à cette affaire donc
ya pas d'anonymat pour nous l'anonymat
n'est jamais une solution de confort en
fait c'est aussi pour se prémunir
d'éventuelles représailles
professionnels d'éventuelles
représailles personnel pour elles dans
leur vie et puis sur les réseaux sociaux
si c'est extrêmement difficile de
pouvoir porter ses paroles l'une de ces
femmes est élu d'ailleurs encore
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'ils vous ont
raconté en substance alors il ya
beaucoup de similitudes dans leur rifi
elles ne se connaissent pas vous l'avez
dit par contre les faits qu'elle dénonce
se serait produit dans la même période
en 2009 2010 2011 à une époque où damien
abad président des jeunes centristes le
mouvement du nouveau centre de jeunesse
du nouveau centre mais il est aussi
député européen et c'est à ce moment 10
tels que il y aurait eu un sentiment un
petit peu de toute puissance et
d'impunité de sa part ce qu'elles
décrivent c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
insistant pour l'une laëtitia dont on
arrivait de témoignages il ya quelques
jours elle dénonce une tentative de viol
indique damien abad lors d'une soirée
lui auraient leurs efforts c'est à faire
une fellation et à l'arrivée réussi en
se débattant à s'extraire de la pièce
est les deux autres dénoncent un viol
l'une dit s'être réveillé après avoir bu
un verre avec lui dans un bar dans une
chambre d'hôtel lendemain elle dit avoir
fait un black out elle dit avoir eu le
sentiment d'avoir été drogué la
troisième elle explique que après un
flirt et un début de relation consentie
il l'aurait contrainte à des pratiques
sexuelles qu'elle ne souhaitait pas elle
dit lui avoir demandé plusieurs fois de
s'arrêter sur ces trois femmes une a
porté plainte elle a porté plainte deux
fois deux plaintes qui ont été à ce
stade classé sans suite oui alors une
première fois en 2012 ensuite elle n'a
pas rappelé le policier pour confirmer
sa plainte elle avait trop peur dit elle
la seconde fois effectivement le dossier
est examiné par la justice mais quelque
chose qui est frappant c'est que alors
même que damien abad dans sa défense
disait qu'il n'avait pas pu commettre
physiquement en raison de son handicap
les gestes qu'on lui prêtait il est la
justice n'a pas mandaté des experts
jeudi de médical pour faire un petit peu
là la part des choses entre ce qu'ils
pouvaient ou pas faire comme geste dans
la vie courante c'est assez frappant
damien abad effectivement qui a été
réélu dimanche soir députés dans l'ain
et qui a considéré d'ailleurs cette
occasion ses électeurs comme je le cite
des juges de paix ni les faits du moins
leur caractère présumant présumément
criminels invoque effectivement sont
handicap qui est une maladie congénitale
pour expliquer qu'il n'a pas pu forcer
qui que ce soit vous l'avais dit la
justice
a retenu si l'on peut dire cet argument
dans l'un des dossiers qu'est ce qu'on
peut penser de cette défense alors c'est
une défense qui a ulcéré pas mal de gens
au point que après le premier article
j'ai reçu beaucoup de témoignages
des témoignages de femmes mais aussi des
témoignages d'hommes qui ont été témoins
ou confident destinataires de
confidences l'un d'entre eux était
assistant parlementaire au parlement
européen au moment où d'amis rabat de
l'état il était au même groupe il me dit
moi ça va ça m'a mis hors de moi parce
que moi je les ai vus se comporter avec
des collaboratrices en soirée de manière
déplacée inappropriée et son handicap
n'était pas un sujet au contraire selon
lui il a joué aussi de ce handicap ça
c'est la parole de certains témoins les
femmes qui l'accusent disent que pour
l'une qu'elle a été très surprise de la
force qui était celle de damien abad
qu'elle n'avait pas imaginé donc c'est
une défense qui est remise en cause par
les plaignantes aujourd'hui moi je ne
rentre pas dans ce débat ce que je note
c'est que d'amener un badge de les
questionner pour ce second volet d'
enquête je lui ai posé 14 questions
extrêmement détaillé aucune réponse
silence radio il n'a pas répondu son
avocat n'a pas répondu sa conseillère
presse n'a pas répondu au ministère
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
m'interpelle les accusations sont graves
on parle d'une tentative de viol il ne
conteste rien quant aux jo le questionne
c'est après l'article qu'il va faire une
déclaration dans un communiqué en disant
que ce sont des allégations fausses
qu'il dément mais sur le fond il ne
répond pas à nos questions il veut aussi
quelque chose d'avéré il ya des sms
qu'il a envoyée c'était pas ya dix ans
c'était mi mai au moment de mes
questions pour le premier article alors
que je le questionne notamment sur les
faits qui concernent une jeune femme
membre de l air il va prendre son
téléphone damien abad alors qu'il vient
d'être nommé ministre il va appeler
cette jeune femme si elle a parlé à
mediapart il ne va pas démentir les
faits dont elle accuse un comportement
déplacé qui serait intervenue à quelques
années à son égard il ne nie pas dans
les messages les faits il lui demande si
elle a parlé à mediapart est ce que
c'est un comportement qu'on peut
attendre d'un ministre la première salve
de révélations qui concerne les deux
premières femmes a eu lieu donc au
lendemain de la nomination d' amir abad
au poste de ministre des solidarités la
première ministre dit avoir découvert
les faits en lisant mediapart d'un mot
ce n'est pas vrai c'est ce que vous
dites je les questionner le vendredi et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui la question
n'est plus de savoir s'ils savaient pas
puisque ils le maintiennent et c'est un
choix politique la premier ministre
première ministre elisabeth baume disait
mi mai que s'il y avait de nouveaux
éléments elle en tirerait toutes les
conséquences ces nouveaux éléments il y
en a pour l'instant pas pas suffisant
visiblement se fera pas en fait c'est
que dans le monde du travail un
employeur une entreprise ne peut pas se
comporter comme la première ministre ou
emmanuel macron avec le gouvernement
dans le monde du travail quand il ya des
signalements sur des faits de
harcèlement sexuel ou de faits plus
graves de violence sexuelle qui ne sont
pas au stade des poursuites judiciaires
même plainte ou pas plein dans le monde
du travail on doit agir l'employeur est
tenu de mettre en pratique des mesures
de précaution suspende par exemple à
titre conservatoire mettre à pied à
titre conservatoire la personne mise en
cause et déployer toute une enquête
interne c'est un principe de précaution
auquel il est tenu il a l'obligation de
l'employeur d'assurer la sécurité de ses
salariés on voit que ce n'est pas du
tout le choix que faye macron et que
fait matignon aujourd'hui sur cette
affaire à l'initiative de l'observatoire
des violences sexistes et sexuelles qui
a eu dans l'un des dossiers accès à la
faire et qu'il a transmis à la justice
188 femmes dont adèle haenel avec
laquelle vous avez beaucoup travaillé
demande dans une tribune du monde qui
est paru ces dernières heures l'as que
damien abad et démissionne on va voir un
extrait de cette tribune je la cite ce
maintien de damien abad donc au
gouvernement signe complicité avec les
hommes violents nous ne sommes pas dupes
nous avons bien conscience qu'il est
question d'éviter un précédent d'éviter
que la démission de damien abad ne
vienne entraîner pour les mêmes motifs
celle de gérald darmanin qui est je le
précise ministre de l'intérieur alors
que le gouvernement alors le
gouvernement décide d'être complice que
penser de ces mots pas ce qui est
certain c'est qu'on ne comprend pas très
bien quelle est la règle de l'exécutif
compte est ce qu'un ministre mis en
cause par des révélations doit
démissionner par exemple dans le cas
d'une mise en examen comme
c'est le cas d'eric dupond-moretti pour
une affaire de viol sexuel mais pour une
affaire de conflit d'intérêts il ne
démissionne pas dans le cas de damien
abad mis en cause dans des révélations
dans la presse il ne démissionne pas
dans le cadre de gérald darmanin qui a
été visée qui est encore visé
aujourd'hui même si on s'achemine vers
un non lieu par une enquête pour viol il
ne démissionne pas donc dans ce
gouvernement quand est ce qu'on
démissionne on peut se souvenir de
georges tron en 2011 à la seconde où son
il est visé par deux accusations
d'agressions sexuelles et de plantes il
démissionne ou plus récemment de taabo à
la france ainsi mises qui sait voilà et
puis dans d'autres affaires on a vu par
exemple françois de rugy démissionné
après une histoire d' usage des fonds
publics donc on a l'impression que sur
les violences sexuelles c'est une sorte
de bulle à part où finalement le
gouvernement pour ne prend pas la mesure
de la gravité des accusations et aussi
de du symbole qui est de maintenir deux
hommes en l'occurrence deux ministres
accusés de violences sexuelles damien
abad et gérald darmanin d'autant que
dans ces deux dossiers il ya des choses
qui sont avérées ya des sms qui montre
des comportements insistants qui montre
dans le cas de gérald darmanin que deux
femmes viennent le voir pour lui
demander de l'aide l'une pour un dossier
jeudi vers l'autre pour une demande de
logement et que en tant qu'élu il va
avoir des relations sexuelles avec elle
ça il le reconnaît il estime juste
qu'elles sont consentis et il va faire
des courriers d'intervention pour leur
dossier est ce que c'est un comportement
pour un élu qui aujourd'hui ministre de
l'intérieur et donc à ce titre en charge
des violences sexuelles notamment gérald
maintenant donc vous l'avez dit dont on
rappelle qu'il a bénéficié d'un non lieu
requis par le parquet au mois de janvier
de cette année que répondez-vous marine
turchi à ceux qui vous accusent d'avoir
été choisi sciemment la date de vos
révélations c'est à dire avant et
pendant les législatives et d'autre part
de jeter en pâture je cite les propos
qui sont tenus le nom d'un homme qui ne
fait donc pour l'instant l'objet
d'aucune mise en examen alors d'abord
c'est le travail des journalistes
d'enquêter sur des faits d'intérêt
public les violences sexuelles font
partie des faits sur lesquels on enquête
au même titre que les affaires
financières la corruption etc donc je ne
vois pas pourquoi on enquêterait pas là
dessus sur le calendrier politique moi
ce qui me frappe c'est que si on publie
avant la nomination d'un ministre on va
nous dire mais vous voulez empêcher sa
nomination si on publie après on va nous
dire ah mais vous et obtenir une
démission qui ont publié avant le
premier tour des législatives on va nous
dire voulait briser les élections s'ils
ont pu les après les élections on va
nous dire vous avez voulu le protéger il
n'y a jamais de moment pour publier une
affaire et surtout une affaire de
violences sexuelles parce que la société
une partie la société peine encore
entendre que ce sont des faits d'intérêt
public mais il faut bien comprendre une
chose on publie une enquête quand elle
est prête et il est évident que après un
an et demi dans quête appartement où il
ya un signalement qui est adressé au
parquet de paris au mois de mai et puis
à l heure est à l heure où m moi je suis
contrainte de poser la question des
alertes qu'ont fait les partis
politiques qui ont été saisis du
signalement du témoignage de chloé de
cette alerte on les tue en rester là
maglica est la république en marche
exactement et puis surtout on peut aussi
se dire que quand un homme politique qui
accusé de violences sexuelles est nommé
au gouvernement c'est un déclencheur
pour beaucoup de gens et notamment pour
celles qui se disent victimes de cet
homme c'est insupportable on se souvient
du rouge à lèvres de denis baupin le
jour de la journée internationale des
droits des femmes il ya le même effet
pour damien battre quand son nom circule
comme potentiel minute quand son nom est
dit sur le perron de l'elysée c'est
insupportable pour certaines femmes de
leur point de vue à elle vu qu'elles se
disent victimes de violences sexuelles
on peut le comprendre et donc c'est
aussi ça qui déclenche le signalement de
chloé et puis la parole qui se débloque
pourquoi damien abad n'attaque pas ces
femmes pour dénonciation calomnieuse
alors c'est assez intéressant le silence
radio de damien abad aujourd'hui il n'a
porté plainte contre personne à ma
connaissance ni en diffamation contre
médiapart non dénonciation calomnieuse
contre ces femmes peut-être le fera t-il
je ne sais pas mais il n'a rien répondu
encore une fois à nos quatorze questions
je lui ai proposé un entretien faut bien
comprendre que c'est pas un coup de fil
24 heures la publication c'est une
demande d'entretien s'est enquis qu'il a
refusé à deux reprises et s'est ensuite
des questions extrêmement détaillées il
avait tous les éléments pour répondre
dans certaines questions il ya des
éléments précis sur des sms qu'il
envoyait sur notamment on peut évoquer
le cas de louise sept anciennes miss
pays de l'ain à qui il envoyait d'après
les éléments que j'ai des messages
extrêmement insistant pendant des années
alors qu'il était député de la
circonscription et membres des jurys au
cal candidate est ça ce sont des faits
avérés il n'a rien répondu c'est un
silence radio qui est très étonnant
merci beaucoup marine turchi d'être venu
ce matin sur le plateau de parer direct
on peut retrouver vos enquêtes et pas
que sur ce sujet bien sûr sur le site de
médiapart je rappelle je précise que
vous avez cosigné une partie de l'anc
est avec
vie merci encore bonne journée à vous on
se retrouve juste après la pause avec
dany coquet attentes